Consciousness is something like an error
detection and rectification system,
something like that.
And so you can say,
well,
you can practice being conscious because
what that means in some sense is you're
always attending to your errors.
Not seems to be a really intelligent
thing to do if you don't take it too far
and collapse yourself.
Because if you're always
attending to your errors,
you're always improving
your automated adaptability,
something like that,
right?
Pay Attention,
see if things are working out
the way that you want them to.
And if they're not,
modify your,
your,
your approach,
your perceptions.
Okay.
So you've conserved the systems
and the systems emerged to,
to solve the problems of the emergent
complexity and you end up at birth with
all of these conserved systems.
And so those would be proclivities
that would enable you to
manifest necessary realm
of behaviors in the social,
natural,
human environment,
something like that.
So you're basically prepared for that.
And I,
I told you I went through what those were
last time and you can break them down
into um,
self-maintenance motivations and
self propagation motivations,
something like that.
So,
okay,
now the question is how did
those manifest themselves?
And that's where we get,
that's where we can make a shift,
say from evolutionary ideas and
biological ideas to narrative ideas.
So I,
I've made the case for
you that you exist within,
within this thing.
I've never figured out exactly what to
call it because you can call it a game or
you can call it a frame of reference,
which is pretty good one.
Or you can call it a story.
Um,
or you can call it a unit of perception.
But it,
that's not exactly right cause
it's more than perception.
It's really this,
it's a really what it is
is a micro personality.
It's,
it's your,
it's your personality as
it manifests itself at it,
at the highest possible resolution.
That's what this is.
And so if I'm,
you know,
let's say I set myself the task of
moving those keys from there to here.
So my perceptual frame is,
it's this thing,
I think,
well what's the world?
Everything else can be ignored.
I need to make an object out of my hand,
these keys,
that tiny spot on the table.
And,
and my goal is to transform
this pattern into that pattern.
And it's a pattern because it
maintains itself across time,
right?
It's not like smoke or cloud.
It persists.
So there it is.
There it is.
That's a pattern that's
extending across time.
So I have this goal,
which is the transformation of
this into that and that goal.
So that would be roughly speaking,
the goal is point B.
But you can't just think about this as
something that's a goal because it isn't
just a goal.
There's a goal,
which is the end,
which is the end state
of this entire process.
The End State is,
I've moved the thing from here to here.
I've transformed this into this
and I've done it using action.
And that's,
so that's a useful thing to know too.
I have an abstract notion.
That's my decision that I'm going to
get the world to manifest this pattern
instead of this one.
Okay?
So that gives me my target.
Okay,
that's an abstraction.
Good,
good.
But when I actually do the transformation,
that's not an abstraction because
now I'm using actual action,
actual behavior.
And so I take this
abstract micro personality.
This is the part that's operating on
this tiny little section of the world.
I make the transformation
and as soon as I do that,
another thing happens,
which is I don't need that anymore.
Right?
I moved to the next one of those,
whatever it happens to be.
And so one of the things we're going
to have to figure out is what is the
relationship between these things?
Because you're always in one
of them and they're scalable.
So like when you're
doing a specific action,
it's really high resolution and that's
kind of where you want to be operating.
When you know what you're doing,
that's where you want to be operating,
roughly speaking,
when you're trying to do something new,
but it's scalable.
And so that's the framework
which is constructed in
part from these motivational
systems that he merged over.
Evolutionary history.
The framework specifies
the current condition,
the desired condition,
and am the behavioral manifestations
that are necessary to make the
transformation.
And so you can't think about it as a drive
cause its instincts are often thought
about is drives or as a goal.
It's not correct because the thing
actually determines your perceptions.
It determines what objects manifest
themselves to you in the world or,
or what patterns.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Cause like when I'm looking at this,
it,
it's hard to watch your own perceptions.
But when I'm looking at this,
I really,
I can see that chair.
But if I didn't know it was a chair,
I wouldn't be able to tell by looking by,
by my visual input,
I can kind of see this one.
Okay.
Although I really can't
tell what color it is.
That one slightly clearer.
This is pretty blurry here.
Like I can't see my fingers.
If I'm looking at the keys,
I can't see my fingers unless they move.
And I'm very,
very focused on that.
So what happens is that all the rest of
the world turns into a low resolution
representations that
vanishes on its periphery.
The resolution increases as uh,
as I moved towards the central
part of my visual field.
And here it's sharp enough so that I can
actually see the letters on that key.
So,
so my desire,
which I am indicating
by the point of my eyes,
is specifying the objects that I see and
specifying their level of resolution.
So you can't just call
that a drive or a goal.
It's,
it's,
that's not right.
It's,
it's the mechanism that makes
the world manifest itself to you.
So that's,
that's,
uh,
unbelievably crazy thing is that the
world manifest itself to you in keeping
with your goals.
Now,
that doesn't mean that you can make the
world do any old thing because it pushes
back,
right?
It objects to you.
So,
but still,
it's,
it's very strange thing that,
okay,
so fine.
So it specifies your perceptions,
your target,
the current reality and the likely
procedure that you're going to use to make
all of that interrelated.
But it does more than that.
So let's,
we're gonna,
we're gonna look at it from a
couple of different perspectives.
So the classic
and archaic way of thinking
about perception has the
world's full of objects.
You see the objects,
you think about them,
you evaluate them.
And then you act on them.
It's like,
no,
that isn't how it works.
First of all,
the world is not made out of objects.
The world is made out of.
I think the world is made out of tools
and obstacles and it's because you can't
not perceive the world in relationship
to you and what you perceive actually or
the meaning of objects
you perceive the patterns.
A tool is something like a meaningful
pattern or useful pattern in something
like that.
And so look,
look again,
you look at,
I might say to someone
described this room,
now you're going to pick,
you're going to pick a level of
description that's very particular.
You're going to pick one that other
human beings could understand.
So it's going to be
predicated on an on your size,
for example.
And so you're going to be predicated on
your knowledge that that other person is
a lot like you and has a lot of the same
underlying structures and motivations.
So,
and that's an implicit
predicate of your description.
So we're going to say,
well,
it's kind of an ordinary classroom.
It's got 20 rows of tables that each
have five chairs at it and each of them
does,
has five chairs.
There's some posts that hold them up.
Um,
there's a couple of speakers.
There's a podium,
there's a screen,
there's some additional chairs,
there's a scattering of people.
There are some electronic equipment.
And so you know,
of course that there's an infinite
number of things I could be describing in
this room.
Right?
Like I could be describing,
there's a lot of color
variation in that tile.
So if I look at it,
I can see that it's unlike the other
tiles because the light is reflecting off
it.
So it's got a shiny white element.
There's about,
God only knows a million different
scratches in it each which are unique.
I can't even really tell what color it is.
It kind of looks like
an off grayish green.
But if I was painting it to get
a reasonable representation,
I'd had to have to have at least six or
seven shades of green ranging from quite
dark to almost white.
And that's only if I look at it from here.
If I look at it from here,
well then you get the point,
right?
I mean there is an infinite
number of details in this room.
There's an infinite number
of facts in this room.
That's also why I don't believe
that you can derive an art form.
It is,
it's like,
you know,
that's the old humean issue,
right?
You cannot derive ethical
guidelines from factual knowledge.
And I think the reason for that
is which facts are going to pick?
How are you going to select them?
There's,
there's an infinite number of them,
even in a constrained situation.
So merely by attending to some
and not attending to others,
you're already using an ethic because
you can't attend to one thing and not
another without being ensconced
in one of these value structures.
Because the value structure
is what determines the
direction of your attention.
And so you can't make the
argument that you're using the,
the infinite number of facts that are
available at your disposal to govern how
you're looking at the facts.
You're not,
that isn't what you're doing.
It's not possible to do that.
So what do you do?
Well,
you described the things in the room
that would be relevant to other people.
Otherwise you're going to bore them to
death or they're going to think you're
insane,
you know,
so,
or an artist maybe because an artist
might do the kind of concentration on a
detail that I just described,
but he's obviously,
or she's obviously trying to paint
the thing are represented somehow.
So it's still tool like,
well why do you want to know
that there are tables while,
cause you said at the,
why do you want to know
if there are chairs?
Because you sit in them.
No,
what about the screen or the camera
equipment while they're all usable tools.
And so that's what you described.
You described the world at the level
of usable tool or you might also say,
um,
you know,
look out for that girl who's
third in the third row,
she's trouble.
And so you might call out
someone if you're describing
the room because there is
somewhere in that room that if you go,
you're going to get into trouble.
And so and so.
Those are sort of the things
that seem to me to be relevant.
There are tools that
move you along your way.
Facilitators,
that's another way of thinking about
that and there are obstacles that get in
your way and there's a tiny set of those.
Otherwise you get overwhelmed.
You're not going to go anywhere
where it's all obstacles,
right?
You don't even mind.
You don't want to be in that place.
You want to be at a place where
it's mostly this and then,
then there's a,
the biggest category though,
this is what's cool,
this is,
and this is so important,
is the biggest perceptual category is
that which is not relevant at this time
because it contains everything.
You know,
like when you're,
when you're writing on this,
on this pad,
you assumed the entire world around you
is constant and therefore you can ignore
it.
It's everything out there.
All the transformations
that are taking place,
you turned to zero and you just focus
on maybe the space that's occupied by a
single letter.
The whole world Trinks down to just that
single letter and everything else is
ignored.
Well,
what happens if something goes wrong?
This is the thing.
This is why this is important.
What happens if something goes wrong?
An indeterminate set of those irrelevant
entities has now become relevant.
That's the problem is the
invisibility disappears.
And so,
for example.